jetzt geht es um Hilal deren
Verschwinden 1999 die größte Suchaktion
in der Geschichte Hamburgs auslöste
genutzt hat es leider nichts
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wir wieder Mirko Kasimir und
Toni Heyer willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland heute ist unser Thema ein
trauriger Cold Case das sind Fälle die
ich immer wirklich ganz besonders hart
und schwer zu ertragen finde aber Mirko
für uns einen in den Fall ja leider geht
es mal wieder um ein verschwundenes Kind
die Tragödie nimmt ihren Lauf am
Mittwoch dem 27 januar 1999 im
regnerischen nur vier Grad kalten
Hamburg Lurup in der Nähe der
S-Bahn-Station Elbgaustraße
es ist schon um die Mittagszeit und
definitiv kein Wetter um großartig viel
Zeit draußen zu verbringen so macht sich
die zehnjährige türkischstämmige
Schülerin Hilal Erkan auf mit der
Erlaubnis ihrer Eltern die wenigen
Minuten hinüber zum Einkaufszentrum
elbgau Passage
Hilal ist eine gute Schülerin sie
interessiert sich wie alle Kids in dem
Alter hauptsächlich für Mode Filme und
die Spice Girls mit zehn Jahren dass die
Welt absolut noch in Ordnung Jungs die
sind weitgehend doof manche sind schon
süß aber die meisten sind doof wichtiger
sind da eher die Freundinnen die Frisur
und Klamotten die man am liebsten Kino
von Weise aus den Geschäften
rausschleppen würde
wäre es noch nicht bemerkt hat ich
spreche da aus Erfahrung vieler er kann
stürmt die Treppen mit dem macht
geschossigen Wohnblock hinunter um sich
schnell ein paar Süßigkeiten im Spar
Markt der elbgaubassagen zu besorgen
Süßkram dehnt sie sich in Anerkennung
für ihre guten Zensuren selbst aussuchen
darf was Hilal in dem Moment denkt
wissen wir nicht aber vielleicht grübelt
sie schon darüber nach wie sie ihren
Geschwistern heute Abend den besten
Platz vor dem Fernseher abluchsen kann
oder sie freut sich einfach nur darauf
später mit ihrer besten Freundin Sandra
zu telefonieren und ja Toni Hilal hat
sich modesch nach dem Geschmack der 90er
Jahre gekleidet Plateau Sneaker dunkler
Blouson dunkle Jeans ein Knall oranges
Sweatshirt und bunter Modeschmuck der
sehr gut zu ihren tiefschwarzen Haaren
passt ich schaue mir gerade ein Foto von
Hilal an dass damals veröffentlicht wird
als klar ist dass sie verschwunden ist
auf dem Foto da ist ein wirklich
eigentlich lustiges aufgewecktes Mädchen
mit ausdrucksstarken Augen und einem
verschmitzten Grinsen zu sehen auf mich
wirkt sie absolut selbstbewusst und das
ist sicher auch der Grund weshalb sich
die Eltern ayla und Kamil Erkan erstmal
keine großen Sorgen machen als der
Einkauf ihrer Tochter etwas länger
dauert aber es vergeht mehr als eine
Stunde die Eltern werden langsam nervös
als erstes fragen Sie bei bekannten
herum aber keiner weiß etwas dann zögern
ayla und Kamil er kann nicht mehr länger
und rufen die Polizei das will man sich
gar nicht vorstellen wie die Eltern sich
dabei gefühlt haben müssen in diesem
Moment als sie beschlossen haben wir
rufen jetzt die Polizei wir schalten die
Behörden ein vielleicht haben Sie aber
auch da schon gespürt dass ihre Tochter
nicht einfach so von zum Beispiel einer
Freundin aufgehalten wurde oder die Zeit
vergessen hat sie kennen Ihr Kind dafür
einfach viel zu gut die Hamburger
Polizei wird sofort aktiv ähnliche vor
tauchen im Alltag der Beamten oft auf
und den Behörden ist klar solche
Vermisstenfälle müssen innerhalb der
ersten 12 Stunden aufgeklärt werden denn
falls es tatsächlich zu einem Verbrechen
gekommen sein sollte dann könnte das
Opfer mit dem Täter noch irgendwie in
der Region unterwegs sein dann besteht
eine Chance von
95%, dass sich der Sachverhalt schnell
klärt das passiert in Deutschland
täglich bis zu 300 Mal
Vermisstenmeldungen gehen bei den
Ermittlungsbehörden ein und die müssen
dann abwägen ob es in Zusammenhang damit
auch zu einem Gewaltverbrechen gekommen
sein könnte
aber zurück zu Hilal auch hier ist Eile
geboten und so wird die polizeiliche
ermittlungskaskade losgetreten der
nähere Umkreis wird mit Streifenbeamten
nach verdächtigen Fahrzeugen wie
Kleinbussen und Lieferwagen abgesucht
als gegen 18 Uhr die Glocken der Kirchen
im nasskalten Nieselregen Leuten sind
schon dutzende Beamte in Hamburg Lurup
im Einsatz erste Passanten und Zeugen in
der Gegend werden befragt später werden
auch Suchanzeigen in Form von
Flugblättern verteilt eine Zeugin sagt
der Polizei sogar sie habe zum Zeitpunkt
des Verschwindens von Hilal die Schreie
eines Mädchens gehört zwei Busfahrer
wollen zur vermuteten Tatzeit einen
großen kräftigen Mann mit rötlichen
Haaren beobachtet haben der auf dem
Parkplatz des Einkaufszentrums am Arm
eines dunkelhaarigen Mädchens zog das
geschätzte Alter des Mädchens passt zu
Hilal hat so gruselig und auch eine
Sache ich in diesem Fall besonders
erschütternd finde ist dass in der Nähe
des Parkplatzes wenig später die
Haarspangen und ein Ohrring hin als
gefunden wurden und zwar von ihrer
eigenen Mutter die wie von sind die
ganze Gegend nach Hilal absucht was die
Polizei nun schon wenige Stunden nach
dem Verschwinden hilals gesichert weiß
das Kind geht um 13:15 Uhr los und wird
kurz darauf noch vom ansässigen
Gemüsehändler der die Familie kennt
gesehen und es gibt einen Kassenbon aus
dem Spar-Markt der zu Hilal passen
könnte um 13:22 Uhr geht eine Packung
hubabuba über die Theke Hilles Lieblings
Kaugummis nur kann sich die Kassiererin
leider nicht mehr daran erinnern wer die
Dinge gekauft hat
aber es liegt nahe dass es Hilal war sie
hatte exakt eine D-Mark für eine Packung
dabei
hatte bei mir auch eine ganz große Phase
die sind einfach perfekt um riesige
Blasen damit zu machen die dann
aufplatzen und im gesamten Gesicht
rumhängen also ich kann mich in Hilal
richtig gut rein versetzen und ich muss
sagen das macht diesen Fall auch
irgendwie so besonders schlimm ich
glaube weil jeder sich irgendwie in
dieses kindliche Setting reinversetzen
kann diese unbesorgtheit
die große Frage ist wo kann Hilal nur
stecken tja und das weiß zu dem
Zeitpunkt leider niemand was im kleinen
Umkreis des Einkaufscenters beginnt
wächst sich schnell zu einer der größten
Fahndungen aus die Hamburg je erlebt hat
Hundertschaften durchkämmen die kleinen
Waldgebiete im Nordwesten Hamburgs
Hubschrauber und Flugzeuge scannen mit
Wärmebildkameras die Waldstücke und
brachen in der Region um Hamburg Luruper
das kalte Wetter ist dabei hilfreich
auch geringste wärme-signaturen gut
erkennen zu können doch keine der
gefundenen Spuren führt zu Hilal die
Polizei mischt parallel das Milieu
unbekannte Pädophile kriminelle auf aber
auch aus dieser Szene lassen sich keine
echten Hinweise auf den Verbleib von
ziehen
[Musik]
dann passiert etwas was erst Hoffnung
macht nur um die Familie gleich erneut
in Düsternis der Trauer und Ungewissheit
zu stürzen es gibt nämlich einen Anruf
bei den erkans am dritten februar 1999
Leute das Telefon bei Hilles Familie
seit Tagen läuft jetzt schon die
verzweifelte Suche nach ihrer Tochter
Polizei und Familie sammeln alle
Informationen die irgendwie helfen
können um die schlimmsten Befürchtungen
auszuräumen am anderen Ende der Leitung
meldet sich eine Männerstimme der
Anrufer bestellt viel als Eltern zur
Christuskirche im Stadtteil eines Büttel
nur ein paar Kilometer von hier als zu
Hause entfernt der Anrufer behauptet
etwas über Hinweis verbleibt zu wissen
doch das Treffen platzt der
vermeintliche Anrufer taucht nicht auf
vielleicht ist er von polizeiaktivitäten
an der Kirche die aber gar nichts mit
hilals Verschwinden zu tun haben
abgeschreckt die Eltern hören nie wieder
etwas von jedem Anrufer
ob hinter dem Anruf wirklich etwas
steckt oder sich nur jemand wichtig
machen wollte werden wir wohl nie
erfahren ein unglücklicher Zufall falls
der Anrufer aber tatsächlich durch den
anderen polizeiansatz an der Kirche
verschreckt wurde das ist furchtbar
ärgerlich aber dafür kann die Polizei
Hamburg auch nichts
was man ihr aber zu Last legen kann ist
das fanatische einschießen auf Familie
Erkan als Täter wenn jetzt auch aus
allen Wolken fallt dann seid ihr nicht
alleine das ging uns in den Recherchen
ganz genauso gut man muss zugeben dass
es von hilals Oma Fatma vorsichtig
formuliert ziemlich ungeschickt ist
falsche Angaben zum tatag zu machen sie
behauptet mit zwei Freundinnen unterwegs
gewesen zu sein während sie eigentlich
heimlich ihren Ex-Mann trifft denn diese
weiterhin bestehende Beziehung zu ihm
will sie vor ihrer Familie verheimlichen
deswegen die Geheimniskrämerei die
Widersprüche in die Oma Fatma sich
verheddert bringen die Polizei auf den
Trichter dass Sie als Familie Achtung
dass die Mädchen in die Türkei
verschleppt und zwangsverheiratet hat
klar was auch sonst also entschuldigung
aber das geht gar nicht nee ich glaube
wenn Kinder verschwinden ist es
natürlich auch die Pflicht dass man in
alle Richtungen ermittelt aber die
Vehemenz der monatelang nur in diese
eine Richtung ermittelt und mit der die
trauernde Familie Mal trittiert wird das
hinterlässt natürlich Spuren bis heute
ist das Verhältnis von Polizei und
Familie Erkan zutiefst gestört die
Familie vertraut der Polizei nicht mehr
also wenn du mich fragst ist das auch
kein Wunder die Vorverurteilung der
Familie spiegelt sich ja sogar im
soko-namen wieder Soko Morgenland und
ganz ehrlich ich hoffe ja fast schon
dass die SOKO deshalb so genannt wird
weil man glaubt dass Hilal in der Türkei
ist denn sonst ist der Name noch viel
furchtbarer ein kleines Mädchen
verschwindet und die SOKO die nach ihr
suchen soll heißt nach dem Geburtsort
ihrer Eltern
wie absurd und sorry
rassistisch ist das denn stell dir mal
vor ein Junge verschwindet im Prenzlauer
Berg und die SOKO heißt Schwabenländle
das ist geschmacklos ja aber schlimmer
finde ich dass durch den Fokus auf die
Familie der wahre Täter wahrscheinlich
unbemerkt seine Spuren verwischen kann
irgendwann bemerkt die Polizei dass sie
sich in einer Sackgasse befindet und
erklärt im Herbst 1999 die Familie frei
von einem Verdacht trotzdem werden
manche Spuren nicht wieder aufgenommen
wie zum Beispiel die vom wikingermann
genau ihr erinnert euch wir haben vorhin
davon gesprochen dass verschiedene
Zeugen insgesamt sind es wohl 23 gewesen
einen großen muskulösen Typen mit
rötlichen Haaren gesehen haben wollen
der ein dunkelhaariges Mädchen
weggezogen haben soll
auch ein Busfahrer kommt auf die
Polizeiwache und es wird ein Phantombild
angefertigt mit dem der Zeuge aber nicht
komplett zufrieden ist deshalb wird es
erst mal nicht veröffentlicht und dann
nie wieder nachgebessert der Busfahrer
wird nicht noch einmal eingeladen das
Phantombild von dem Mann der zur Tatzeit
von 23 Zeugen dabei gesehen wird wie er
an einem Mädchen mit hilals
Erscheinungsbild hat wird einfach nie
veröffentlicht das so Panne also der
Wikinger Mann wie dieser Riese mit den
rötlichen Haaren genannt wird der
verschwindet einfach in der Versenkung
trotz dieser Panne mit dem Wikinger Mann
gibt es immer wieder heiße Spuren die
aber jedes Mal ins Leere führen so wird
nur wenige Wochen nach hier als
Verschwinden der Entführer eines anderen
Mädchens in Hamburg geschnappt
die Kleine konnte glücklicherweise
fliehen doch obwohl es Parallelen zum
Fall von Hilal gibt lässt sich dem Täter
in dieser Hinsicht nichts nachweisen und
die Polizei tappt trotz des riesigen
Aufwandes weiter im Dunkeln
fast ein Jahr nach der Tat wird im ZDF
bei Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst um Mithilfe
der Öffentlichkeit gebeten genauso wie
in der RTL2 Sendung ungeklärte Morde dem
Täter auf der Spur auch die
ausgeschriebenen 20.000 DM Kopfgeld
bringen keine wichtigen Erkenntnisse die
zu Hilal oder dem mutmaßlichen Täter
führen der Fall wird zum Cold Case und
die Familie Erkan findet keine Antwort
auf ihre dringendste Frage wo ist Hilal
lebt sie noch das Hilal noch leben
könnte davon geht kaum noch einer der
Ermittler aus aber als deine april 2005
der verurteilte Sexualstraftäter Dirk a
überraschend auch den Mord an Hilal
Erkan gesteht hofft man zumindest auf
eine wenn auch erschütternde Gewissheit
für die Eltern Dirk a behauptet in
seinem Geständnis
ich habe sie in meinem BMW erwirkt weil
sie meinen sexuellen Wünschen nicht
nachgekommen ist er fühlt später
Polizisten zu einer Stelle im Volkspark
wo er sie vergraben haben will und
widerruft dort plötzlich seine Aussage
vermutlich hat er schlicht vom Fall
Hilal gelesen und sein perversen Spaß
dran alle an der Nase herumzuführen oder
er was und lässt es aus den gleichen
wirklich verachtenswerten Gründen offen
die Polizei sucht natürlich trotzdem
kann aber im Volkspark auch nach
intensiver Suche nichts finden
Zitat eines Ermittlers von 2018
ob der verurteilte Sexualstraftäter die
Polizei damals täuschte um sich in
kruder Selbstwahrnehmung als wichtig
erscheinen zu lassen oder ob er sich aus
Feigheit über eventuelle strafrechtliche
Konsequenzen zum rückziehen des
Geständnisses entschloss ist bis heute
fraglich
Dirk a gesteht das ganze nämlich noch
mal nur um dann wieder alles
zurückzuziehen wegen dieses Hin und Hers
gibt es heute viele Ermittler bei der
Hamburger Polizei die sich sicher sind
dass Dirk a Hilal auf dem Gewissen hat
nur fehlen die Beweise und hier ist es
wie bei eigentlich fast allen Fällen so
dass der Fall eine weitere Dimension
bekommt denn der Mörder hat nicht nur
der Familie er kann eine Tochter
genommen durch die Ungewissheit zerstört
er auch das Leben der Eltern und der
Geschwister von Hilal Stück für Stück
versetzt das die Familienbande das ist
eine offene Wunde die Welt und
unsägliche Schmerzen bringt und gefühlt
nie aufhört da hast du völlig Recht der
Fall Hilal Erkan ist bisher der einzige
ungelöste Langzeit Vermisstenfall mit
einem Kind in Hamburg
2017 besuchen Journalisten vom Stern die
Familie sie schildern deren Verzweiflung
Zitat Camel Erkan für meine Frau und
mich ist es immer noch so als sei es
gestern passiert genauso schmerzhaft der
Bruder Abbas fügt hinzu ich bin mit
Schmerz aufgewachsen
die Journalisten berichten auch dass es
kein Bild von Hilal in der Wohnung gibt
sie würden es nicht ertragen und
verwahren auch alle Sachen von Hilal in
einem großen Koffer wie angespannt und
zerstörerisch das Leben mit der
Ungewissheit für die Familie ist das
zeigt sich letztes Jahr auch noch in
Form eines Gewaltausbruchs von hilals
Vater gegen seine Frau Eiler der geht
immer April 2022 mit einem Messer auf
seine Frau los die Tochter will ihm das
Messer abnehmen und wird dabei selbst
verletzt der Grund für den Ausraster des
Vaters von Hilal seine Frau will sich
von ihm trennen Kiel als Vater nun schon
57 Jahre alt versucht nicht sich vor der
Strafe oder der Tat zu drücken tut sich
aber schwer mit Erklärungen
wir waren eine glückliche Familie bis zu
dem schrecklichen Tag als unsere älteste
Tochter Hilal verschwand
während der Aussage bricht er immer
wieder in Tränen aus unser Leben änderte
sich an diesem Tag für immer bis heute
konnten wir keinen Frieden finden
seit hilals verschwinden vor mehr als 20
Jahren leidet die gesamte Familie und
der extremen Verlustängsten ayla ist auf
apathisch und depressiv und Kamel hat
unter allen Umständen versucht nicht
noch mehr Menschen in seinem Leben zu
verlieren und die Familie
zusammenzuhalten
Messerangriff hilfreich ist das würde
ich jetzt bezweifeln aber es klingt nach
einer absoluten Verzweiflungstat diese
Familie die ist gebrochen der Mann ist
gebrochen und dass man dadurch dreht das
kann man nachvollziehen aber es ist halt
keine Entschuldigung
aber klar ist das Leben dieser Familie
ist seit dem 27 januar 1999 komplett
zerstört trotz allem scheint aber die
Familie weiter zusammenzuhalten also
Ayla die Frau von Kami die erscheint
immer wieder vor Gericht und hat ihren
mittlerweile Ex-Mann verständnisvoll
unterstützt am Ende hat Hill als Vater
eine Bewährungsstrafe von 15 Monaten
bekommen
[Musik]
aber auch wenn der Fall nun schon so
lange zurückliegt polizeilich
abgeschlossen ist er natürlich nicht und
selbstverständlich wird er es nie für
die Familie sein auch im Jahr 2022 gibt
es noch neue Hinweise daraufhin
durchsucht die Polizei ein knapp drei
Hektar großes Waldstück am nördlichen
Stadtrand Hamburgs
25 Tage lang durch kämmen Beamte täglich
das Gebiet auch ein Gewässer wird von
Polizei Tauchern abgesucht der Grund für
diese aufwendige Aktion sind alte Akten
eines mehrfach Verurteilten
Sexualstraftäters mit der Durchsuchung
soll geprüft werden ob es auch einen
Zusammenhang mit dem Verschwinden von
Hilal gibt das bleibt aber erstmal
ergebnislos richtig aber im September
2022 wird ein verlassenes Grundstück in
einem Kleingartenverein unmittelbar
neben der A7 durchsucht morgens um 9 Uhr
Rücken Polizisten des Technischen Zuges
auf dem städtischen Areal an der
nansenstraße ein auf dem Grundstück
Fällen die Beamten Bäume beseitigen
erstmal allen Unrat und fangen mit der
detaillierten Spurensuche an und wie die
Beamten auf genau dieses Grundstück
kommen das ist ziemlich interessant
Fernsehen hilft manchmal sogar denn in
einer ndr-doku zum Fall Hilal Erkan
berichtet ein Mann der 1999 noch
minderjährig ist dass er damals auf eben
jenem Grundstück mit dem bis heute als
tatverdächtig geltenden Dirk a viel Zeit
verbringt übrigens liegt dieses
Grundstück nahe beim Volkspark also der
Volkspark der nach Dirk Aas ersten
Geständnis auch schon durchsucht wurde
im Herbst 2022 innerhalb von zwei
Monaten nimmt die Polizei das ganze
Grundstück auseinander
sobald das Bodenradar Unregelmäßigkeiten
aufzeigt wird mit einem kleinen Bagger
der Grund ausgehoben dort wo
Leichenspürhunde anschlagen wird die
Erde gesiebt aber es findet sich nur ein
Knochen und dieser stammt leider oder
vielleicht auch glücklicherweise bloß
von einem Schwein
am Ende muss die Staatsanwaltschaft
konstatieren die Suche sei ergebnislos
abgeschlossen worden die Grabungen
hätten keine neuen Beweismittel zu Tage
gefördert parallel dazu sucht Hilal
erkans Familie auf eigene Faust weiter
sie durchsuchen diese Grundstücke
zwischen Park und Autobahnen bereits vor
der Polizei von der sie mittlerweile nur
noch wenig Unterstützung erwarten und
stoßen damit vielleicht auch die etwas
eingeschlafenen Ermittlungen wieder an
so dass es eben zu dieser großen
Suchaktion von letztem Herbst kommt
natürlich hat es auch Nachteile dass die
Familie selbst ermittelt die Polizei
befürchtet dass sie bei ihrer Suche
Spuren zerstören doch die erkans wissen
sich nicht anders zu helfen sie haben
niemals aufgegeben und suchen immer
weiter zusammen mit dem Verein Opfer
Interessen von Kinder e.V der extra zu
diesem Zweck von Jasmina Hauke gegründet
wurde
schon ihre Mutter hilft den erkans 1999
bei der Suche und gemeinsam haben Mutter
und Tochter nie aufgehört hilals Familie
ehrenamtlich zu unterstützen mir tut das
richtig richtig leid ich verstehe den
Schmerz der Familie und den Drang
endlich Aufklärung über die Umstände
oder wenigstens nur ein Grab zu haben wo
sie trauern können aber nichts der Fall
ist bis heute nicht geklärt hier als
Bruder aber sagte mal zu Bild ich
wünsche mir dass wir endlich Gewissheit
haben wo Hilal versteckt ist der Täter
ist uns das bis heute schuldig wenn er
es sagt dann gebe ich ihm die Chance
dass wir ihm verzeihen er erlöst uns
alle damit und auch die Polizei ist mit
der Situation nicht gerade glücklich der
Hamburger Polizeisprecher Holger wehren
2022 ebenfalls zu Bild wie man die
Situation dort sieht
es ist bedauerlich dass der Fall noch
nicht aufgeklärt ist wir prüfen
regelmäßig ob es neue Ermittlungsansätze
gibt die Akte lila wird nicht
geschlossen
[Musik]
was ich ganz ganz
schwierig für mich selbst finde bei
diesem Fall mir deine Meinung zu bilden
klar man wünscht der Familie irgendwie
dass sie abschließen können oder dass
sie zumindest diesen Schritt in der
Trauer weitergehen können dass sie mit
dieser Ungewissheit leben müssen das
können sie ja anscheinend nicht und das
finde ich völlig nachvollziehbar und
plausibel dass sie sagen wir können
nicht loslassen und wir wir wollen die
Hoffnung auch nicht aufgeben ich kann
mir schon vorstellen dass wenn ein Kind
verschwunden ist und du hast keine
Leiche du weißt nicht ob sie vielleicht
doch leben könnte sozusagen
zu beschließen wir gehen vom Schlimmsten
aus und versuchen irgendwie damit
abzuschließen damit weiterzuleben
ich kann mir vorstellen dass man sich da
als Elternteil oder als Familie als
Geschwister dass man sich da schuldig
fühlt weil du weißt es ja nicht es
besteht ja trotzdem die Hoffnung dass
sie noch leben könnte ja auf jeden Fall
eine sehr sehr zermürbende Situation und
zermürbend ist dann natürlich weit weit
untertrieben aber das ist eine Familie
natürlich über diesen langen Zeitraum
kaputt machen kann
das kann man wirklich nachvollziehen
denn die Last die auf dieser Familie
liegt die wird er nicht weniger und wenn
du halt keine Gewissheit hast dann dann
hält dieser Druck den diese Last ausübt
ja auch über Jahre und Jahrzehnte an und
das ist wahrscheinlich
den kein Mensch so lange aushalten kann
ja dafür finde ich sehr bewundernswert
wie die Familie trotz allem so
zusammenhält weil man hört das ja auch
bei vielen Familien dass sich die Wege
dann eher trennen also viele Paare
trennen sich ja dann auch oder haben das
stimmt haben schlechten Kontakt nur noch
miteinander weil sie es nicht ertragen
und hier ist die Familie ja super eng
und das sieht man ja auch selbst nachdem
wie als Vater leider diesen
Gewaltausbruch hatte hat die Familie
gesagt wir bleiben zusammen wir halten
zusammen das finde ich sehr
bewundernswert woher sie diese Stärke
haben auch das ihr Bruder sagt wenn der
Täter und sagt was mit ihr passiert ist
oder wie wir sie finden können dann
geben wir ihm die Chance dass wir ihm
verzeihen ja so viel Kraft musste
erstmal aufbringen dass du bereit bist
jemandem zu verzeihen der mutmaßlich ein
Mitglied einer Familie getötet hat das
ja das kann man sich möchte man sich
nicht vorstellen aber nach wie vor
bleibt es halt ein Cold Case deshalb
noch mal die dringliche bitte der
Hamburger Polizei
wer hat Hilal am Mittwoch den 27 januar
1999 gegen 13:15 Uhr in der
unmittelbaren Umgebung der elbgaubassage
in Hamburg Lurup gesehen
wer kann etwas zum verbleibt der
Kleidung oder der von Hilal mitgeführten
Gegenstände wie ihren Ohrringen und
ihren Haarspangen sagen wer kann sich an
einen Mann erinnern der in der Nähe der
elbgaubassage an einem Fahrzeug stand
dein hantierte oder den Eindruck
vermittelte auf jemanden zu warten
wem ist am Mittwoch dem 27 januar 1999
nach 13.30 Uhr ein abgestelltes oder um
hier fahrendes Auto in einer abgelegenen
Gegend des Hamburger Randgebietes
aufgefallen Hinweise dazu nimmt das LKA
Hamburg entgegen oder jede andere
Polizeidienststelle die Telefonnummer
dazu haben wir euch auch noch mal in die
Show Notes gepackt vielen Dank dass ihr
heute zugehört habt und wir hoffen dass
Sie auch beim nächsten Mal mit dabei
seid eure Toni und euer Mirko
Skript und Postproduktion wayward
Studios München
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband so weit
unsere Fälle für heute schickt uns gerne
Feedback zu diesem Uploads in den
Sommerferien und zwar an podcast@bild.de
oder auch bei Instagram die Links findet
ihr in den Show Notes und natürlich
freuen wir uns auch in der Urlaubszeit
wenn ihr uns gute Bewertungen dalasst
und uns abonniert da wo ihr Podcast hört
genau und am Samstag wird es
neue Folge gegeben zu einem wirklich
schlimmen politischen Mordanschlag der
sich zum 12 mal Yard eine neue Folge mit
unserem reporterkollegen Peter hell und
einem Skript von Lilly von der Osten
genau also Samstag neue Folge Wecker
stellen wir hören uns